can I have the Matt wall show my expose
on Vanderbilt's gender Clinic which
butchers and drugs kids and that's not
even the worst of it has sparked a
massive reaction on both the right and
the left best of all there's now a push
for legislation to finally put a stop to
this I'll give you the latest on this
story today also the White House walks
back Biden's claim that the that the
pandemic is over they say not so doctors
will now start conducting regular
screenings for anxiety why is that a bad
thing well I'll explain a therapist
brags on Tick Tock about how he
indoctrinates and manipulates kids and
in our daily cancellation a philosopher
comes to the defense of that teacher in
Canada with the giant fake breasts all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Progressive is a totalitarian screaming
to get out and the team at front page
magazine has been unmasking these
totalitarians since the earliest days of
the internet founded by David Horowitz a
former red diaper baby and new leftist
who ultimately became an enemy of the
left and a best-selling author front
page magazine has spent over two decades
combating the radical the radical left's
efforts to destroy America there are two
new podcasts the right take with Mark
tapson and the Jason Hill show offer
riveting interviews and insightful
coverage of politics culture and current
events the right take with Mark tapson
offers a fascinating in-depth cultural
commentary as well as interviews with
well-known conservative thinkers Jason
hell show offers thoughtful deep Dives
about the ideologies of the radical left
and interviews who with renowned
intellectuals like Peter wood and Bruce
Gilley it takes up Village to combat the
radical left's efforts to destroy
America that's why as a fan of my show
you should also check out these guys
over at front page magazine by visiting
frontpagemag.com
and while you're there support they're
caused by making a tax deductible
donation inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and no
one understands that better than the
team at front page magazine so go to
frontpagemag.com today
we moved to Nashville about two years
ago and uh have grown to love the city
and the community here but when I found
out that my local Hospital Vanderbilt
drugs and mutilates kids uh I knew that
that's not something we could tolerate I
don't really want to share this city
with groomers and butchers the town
isn't big enough for both of us you
might say so we decided to investigate
the hospital and I admit that I'm no
journalist but if the actual journalists
aren't going to do their job then it
falls to me and to others on the right
like lives of tick tock and Christopher
and others who have been working to
expose the horrors of gender ideology
and as we dug into this
a story began to reveal itself yesterday
on the show I sort of told you that
story took you took you through it
chronologically started in 2018 with the
unveiling of Vanderbilt's new
transgender clinic and they were
motivated to get into the gender
transition game in large part because of
all the money there is to be made from
it which in and of itself is maybe not a
revelation that they like making money
from this
but it was still interesting to hear the
video that we played of a doctor
boasting about the profitability of
transition surgeries quote unquote she
excitedly declared that bottom surgery
for women which is the construction of
an artificial penis using skin peeled
off of the arm or elsewhere on the body
is such a big quote Money Maker that
some clinics can Thrive financially just
by performing those surgeries alone now
why are they such a cash cow though well
because as she says they're they're
labor intensive and also because they
require lots of follow-up so yes if you
if you get one of these surgeries
you will be doomed to a life of
continued hospital visits as doctors
work to keep your fake sex organs
nominally functional uh it'll be
miserable for you I mean you have signed
on to be a patient forever
but it's great for the doctors of
Vanderbilt and they love it
next we revealed the intimidation
tactics the hospital has used to keep
their staff in line because of course
you know they decided that they're going
to start doing this and not everybody's
on board with it not everybody wants to
butcher people and chop their be a be a
party to this chopping their
um their you know bodies apart and
creating new sex organs and all the rest
of it
and Vanderbilt knew that not everybody
was on board so according to one video
we played staff were warned that if they
conscientiously object or if they
exercised their religious liberty their
first amendment rights and decline to
participate in these procedures quote
there will be consequences and if that
didn't get the message Vanderbilt also
enlisted an army of trans activists to
actually attend appointments with trans
patients to include children and conduct
essentially surveillance of the doctors
making sure that they're all affirming
of the trans identity
and then of course there's the Pediatric
gender Clinic which grew out of the uh
the the overall transgender clinic and
as I proved with video documentation as
much as we hear denials about this sort
of thing now uh the fact is that
Vanderbilt gives chemical castration
drugs to young children they prescribe
cross-sex hormones to 13 year olds which
are irreversible they perform double
mastectomies which are also obviously
irreversible on 16 year olds and they do
all of this
either on a mission
because there's a lot of money to be
made from it
now after I released our expose here on
the show and on Twitter yesterday
it caught fire fortunately my Twitter
thread with all these videos has been
retweeted over 30 000 times in a day and
counting state legislators here in
Tennessee have responded promising that
they will work to ban these practices in
the state our governor Bill Lee issued a
statement
saying in part that Tennessee quote
should not allow permanent life-altering
decisions that hurt children or policies
that suppress religious Liberties he
called for an investigation into
Vanderbilt there's been a response on
the federal level too Senator Marcia
Blackburn echoed the call for an
investigation the majority leader in
Tennessee in the Tennessee House of
Representatives William Lambert tweeted
quote I'm deeply troubled by what Matt
Walsh uncovered about the Pediatric
transgender clinic at vumc Governor Bill
Lee is right to call for an
investigation and we will support that
investigation 100 this type of child
mutilation should be illegal and soon
will be in Tennessee
I can also tell you that I've had people
within Vanderbilt contact me encouraging
me to continue exposing the institution
they work for and offering their help
from the inside
I've been in touch with many activists
and others here locally and across the
country wanting to join in the effort to
shut down Vanderbilt's child Butchery
business
now all of this of course has provoked
the expected reaction from the left they
aren't gonna
engage in any sort of discussion they
aren't going to attempt to defend
Vanderbilt's practices or explain why
it's actually good to chop an adolescent
girl's breasts up they're going to do
that they're going to justify
Vanderbilt's intimidation tactics
against their own health care providers
they aren't going to do any of that
because they can't instead they'll
simply try to have me silenced
and if they can arrange it Arrested too
so just reading through a sampling of
tweets from some verified accounts
and this again is just a small sampling
of what's out there but trans activist
Alejandra carabayo uh posted quote
Vanderbilt Medical Center has had to
shift medical appointments for its trans
Clinic to Virtual Telehealth
appointments as a result of threats
being made Matt Walsh is inciting a
terror campaign against a hospital and
disrupting care he will get people hurt
or killed
this of course is the common theme
you're going to get people killed you're
killing people
by factually reporting on what this
hospital is doing
Noah berlansky who's a bizarre freak
who's written for that creepy Pro
pedophile organization prostasia
um he tweeted uh crying out to Twitter
to shut me down saying Twitter support
how on Earth is Matt Walsh not violating
terms of service you are complicit in
terrorism and you're going to be
complicit in Murder if you don't take
action
this sentiment was echoed by Leah Torres
who's an abortionist who by the way um
if you maybe recognize the name from a
while ago she was the abortionist who
once bragged
about cutting the baby's vocal cords
during an abortion so she can't hear
them scream that's what she said
so she's she responded saying Matt Walsh
is off the rails and he is behaving
dangerously I reviewed his posts just
from today and he's going to get people
hurt and or killed I reported the post
but that hardly feels like enough
now of course coming from her accusing
me of getting people killed I can't even
tell she means that as a compliment
she then tagged the FBI of course
because she wants to get the FBI
involved and so did a leftist creep
named Zach hunt who says Hey FBI and
justice department and mnpd Nashville
Matt Walsh is targeting Vanderbilt
Hospital the same way he targeted Boston
Children's Hospital please intervene
before one of his followers starts
calling in bomb threats or worse
this is the strategy they've of course
long since settled on
and it tells you everything you need to
know
because if there was any possible
defense of these practices
the left would make that argument they
tell us what the defense is
if there's anything they could say to
rationalize it they would say it
but there's nothing there's no defense
Vanderbilt like so many other hospitals
and medical clinics
is enriching itself
by permanently damaging the bodies and
minds of children
it cannot be defended
so instead they cry incitement and hope
that the FBI comes and takes me away
what that means is that is that these
people at some level
they know that we're right
they know it
all the people responding FBI
they all at some level know
that they're the bad guys here
which makes them even a bit even bigger
bad guys makes it makes you even more
evil when you're aware of how evil you
are
they know that this is horrific and
inexcusable and they must recognize that
fact or else they wouldn't be so
desperate to shut down any conversation
about it
if they believe that Vanderbilt was
entirely in the right they would say
yeah Vanderbilt is doing all of that and
it's good thank you for the free
advertisements
yep as a as a comparison
the left likes to um talk about the the
evils perpetrated by pregnancy centers
you know and and of course they say all
these things about pregnancy centers and
then pregnancy centers are actually
physically attacked uh and there's our
sin and and everything else but that's
not incitement
but here's here's the interesting thing
if uh if somebody on the left were to
post a long thread going through David
picking out any Pregnancy Center and
saying look at what this pregnancy
center does and then they post
an accurate description of all the
resources and all of the you know
practices of this pregnancy center
as a supportive pregnancy centers I
would say great yeah that's exactly what
pregnancy centers do thank you for
letting people know please post more
like this
as an advocate and a supporter of
pregnancy centers I am proud of that
if you want to talk about pregnancy
centers we can definitely talk about it
I'm not going to try to shut you down
for talking about it
see that's what you do if you believe
you're in the right
if you believe you're in the wrong then
you you know literally call the police
and try to have me thrown in a jail cell
just for factually reporting about what
this institution is doing and who
they're doing it to
now as for Vanderbilt's response they
have so far issued No statement except
they did in effect issue a statement
when they took down their website for
their transgender clinic now when I say
they took down the website I mean the
whole site they deleted the entire site
getting rid of all the evidence
now unfortunately for them we
anticipated that and we spent uh the
previous week archiving saving videos
and taking screenshots so we have it all
it's too late to get rid of it guys we
have it
I mean what I posted yesterday talked
about the show that's only a small
fraction of what we have we have the
rest of it
but up until now I mean how do we get a
hold of this stuff because up until now
they were posting everything online with
Reckless abandon we didn't dig through
their trash or secretly film them to get
this footage
they filmed it and posted it
the footage of their doctor threatening
reprisals for conscientious objections
was streamed live to Facebook
and then published and posted there and
kept there for two years
same for the video of the woman
admitting to Vanderbilt's greed and
profit motives
streamed it put it on Facebook didn't
even take down the stream afterwards
they didn't even say to themselves oh
well she went uh he went a little off
script there with some of this I think
we're gonna take this down no left it up
there
for years these people did whatever they
wanted and they did it out in the open
without fear of pushback
or of criticism
but those days are over
they're over and they're never coming
back
so if you're in the gender Butchery
business you ought to know that
you operated with impunity for a while
but now that's done
I and I am not satisfied to Simply
report on what Vanderbilt is doing like
I said I'm not a journalist
I will act the part if I have to because
the real journalists won't
but I I have an opinion here I I have a
perspective
I have an agenda
the agenda is protecting kids
and exposing Horrors and atrocities
where they're happening
and the other part of the agenda is to
shut this down
okay we're gonna put a stop to it
we're going to put a stop to it we're
not going to allow
this to happen to children we're going
to make this illegal
that's what happens next
and we're just getting started
now let's get to our five headlines
well I can't say enough good things
about uh my Helix mattress you know we
got we got one Helix mattress and we
gave it to my daughter for her for her
to sleep in and then I felt very jealous
of that so we need to get a second Helix
mattress and now finally my wife and I
have one
um you can get a great night's sleep on
a helix mattress and if you want to see
it for yourself well Helix has several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
mornings aches and pains and even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers very important as well they
also have a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else so
if you're looking for a mattress take
the quiz order the mattress that you're
matched to and wait for the delivery
your mattress will come right to your
door for free you don't ever need to go
to the mattress store again they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
don't love it but you will I guarantee
for a limited time Helix is offering up
to 350 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners this is
their best offer yet so hurry over to
helixsleep.com Walsh
I I should also tell you that um
this is one this is one more reason as
we're as we're we're working on this
with with the story of the Vanderbilt
and as I said this is just you know we
have
we have good plans here I can't lay them
all out yet but
um that that will come soon
and this is really just
the beginning
you know we we are exposing this in
Tennessee because this is where we live
it seems like a logical place to start
but it doesn't end there
uh but I should tell you that and this
is this is the truth that we we cannot
do any of this without our members
supporting us and you might think well
you know why do you need memberships to
post a Twitter Thread about this well
this is actually this is hours of
research and and Manpower that goes into
something like this because even though
they post all this stuff to to the
Internet it's a lot of stuff to sift
through and uh most people just don't
you don't have the time or the energy to
do which is one of the reasons why
they've gotten away with it for so long
um and that's something we're able to
dedicate the resources to because I mean
directly because of our members so if
you are a member thank you for that
thank you for
enabling us to
fight back in this way in a way that's
meaningful to like actually try to make
a difference I sit here every day on the
show talking about all these awful
things happening in the world and it
gets exhausting at times I'm sure it
gets exhausting for
you and the audience
[Music]
um
which is why it's such a relief to know
that we can actually do something about
it to to take some of these things and
say we're not just going to talk about
them we're going to talk about them
first to raise awareness uh but then
we're going to do something about it
all of that is possible because of our
members so thank you to our members if
you're not a member yet we encourage you
to uh think about becoming a subscriber
and join this
team this uh movement that we're
building
so go to daily wire.com and get a
membership today I want to begin with
this in our five in our five headlines
um Turning Point USA has this report on
their website says Dylan Mulvaney is a
man who began publicly identifying as a
female just 191 days ago and demands
others use she them pronouns uh when
referring to him he was invited to speak
at the 2022 Forbes power Women's Summit
Mulvaney posted about his experience
going to the Forbes conference where he
spoke on a panel with two women about
his transition Journey as well as the
social media to mainstream pipeline
problem with his appearance is the
simple fact that he is indeed a man not
a woman who presents himself as an over
dramatized parody of a female now we
have the tweet from Forbes where they uh
they posted you know an image of this
Dylan Mulvaney character and uh the the
four at Forbes women says Dylan Mulvaney
speaks about collaboration and
authorship at the Forbes power Women's
Summit
this is someone that they've invited
to the Women's Summit as a speaker
to address women
and I want to show you this should just
give you an example of the kind of thing
that Dylan posts again as you heard
there just started quote identifying as
a woman like half a year ago okay about
six months ago
and what does that mean for him I mean
what is what does being a woman mean
well here it is let's find out
day 66 being a girl and today I'm in
nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
wind turbine love it Meadows love them
this is supposed to be what women do
is this
a woman or is this like a woodland elf
oh
[Music]
so there's uh that's Dylan Mulvaney's uh
uh Journey becoming a woman
and I only show you that because again
this Forbes invited that person to be a
speaker
at a women's Leadership Summit
in in utter cartoon right a total
mockery of of Womanhood
and every time I see something like this
I I think like have you ever met a woman
have you ever even met one what woman
acts like that this is this is an
impression this is like some sort of it
would seem to be a parody an actual it
would seem almost to be an actual
intentional
parody of of a woman
because if you've ever met one in your
life you would know that nothing about
that
strikes me as remotely uh feminine
this is what they turn women into as
well they turn them into flamboyant gay
men
what do you know big coincidence
and the irony is that on the right we're
always accused anytime we talk about if
we're talking about abortion for example
or pro-life convictions as men the
response from people on the left always
is well you what do you know about women
have you ever even met a woman
a bunch of virgins
this is something they say to me all the
time even though I have six kids now
I've got my I'm driving around my 12
passenger van that I just bought
yesterday by the way uh because my wife
finally did give in and realized we had
to buy the Vans we have this big I'm
driving around my big massive van soon
to be filled with six kids
and then you've got the left a bunch of
childless leftists oh you virgin
which maybe they they maybe they really
mean it because they they don't know
where babies come from they actually
don't understand the the biology of it
and so that makes that's an accusation
that makes sense to them so as much as
they like we always talk about on the
left whatever they say about their
opposition is actually true of them so
it's nothing but projection all the time
and that's the case here because uh this
is this is the the version of Womanhood
that they prop up
which is not Womanhood at all but is
again a satire a parody a cartoon
okay I've never known my wife uh enjoys
being out in nature out in the woods
okay but I've never known her to put on
high heels and and prance through the
forest
spinning around and talking about how
much she loves everything in the forest
that's uh okay
if you got your idea of Womanhood
from watching
uh 1950s Disney cartoons so if you got
your idea of Womanhood from Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs
that's basically what this guy's got
here
that's something that's got snow white
she's she's running through the forest
and singing and the birds are coming and
singing along with her
a literal cartoon
it's what they've turned woman Womanhood
into
I would be uh if I was a woman
which in fact I am not and never could
be
uh
despite popular misconceptions
I would be
deeply
offended by that sort of thing that
would be offensive to me
to be portrayed in that way
all right Joe Biden announced a few days
ago that the pandemic is over the amount
he announced that on 60 Minutes but his
administration isn't quite ready to give
up the pandemic yet they they still have
they still have coveted coordinators on
staff for goodness sake they they have a
they're using their pandemic powers to
Ram through unconstitutional measures
and they probably have some more they
want to do with that power so they need
this they need the pandemic they're not
ready to give it up yet they've got uh
Old Uncle Joe up there babbling about
how the pandemic is over uh going off
script and so now the administration is
in cleanup mode and here is Karen Jean
pair on MSNBC trying your best to clean
up after her boss let's see how she does
President also in the 60 Minutes
interview said that the pandemic is over
there's been quite a bit of pushback to
that uh statement by the president where
is he today on that so just to step back
for a second what we saw during that
interview uh 60-minute interview when he
made those comments he was walking
through uh the the Detroit car show the
halls of the Detroit car show and he was
looking around we have to remember the
last time that they had held that event
was three years ago even as we're
talking about unga the president's going
to speak shortly as I just mentioned we
that hasn't been held in in person for
about three years as well so we are in a
different time he's been very consistent
about that and the reason why is because
we are now prepared we are now ready we
know how to deal with this pandemic it
is now more manageable it's not as
disruptive as it's been in the prior in
the prior years and so and it is because
of what this president has done on day
one if you think of about where we were
when he walked in 3 000 people were
dying a day that has come down 90
percent you think about schools that
were closed now schools are open think
about businesses were closed now
businesses are open and it's because of
the work that this Administration has
done now what he has been very
consistent about is that we have to
continue to have a front foot on this so
we have the funding so that we are ahead
of this of any other you know as we look
at Future vaccines and future treatments
we need to make sure that we are ready
for that as we're also leading as we're
talking uh the backtrack of unga as
we're leading globally as well
pretty good you know I was I'm I have to
admit I don't give her a lot of credit
I'll give her some credit there uh just
in her ability to pretty good job
filibustering there keep on talking keep
on talking to stop them from asking any
follow-ups not that they would have
anyway because it's MSNBC and they're
they're all on the same team but um
she was talking around the issue of
course it usually she doesn't do a very
good job I mean that that is if you're a
White House Press Secretary especially
for a Democrat president that's all
you're ever supposed to do is talk
around the issues not answer any
questions usually she fumbles around
quite a bit with that uh she is getting
a little better she's learning so that's
nice and uh there she talks for about
two minutes
but in summation if we were to summarize
everything she just said she is claiming
that her boss the president United
States was wrong she's she's saying no
he was wrong about that the pandemic is
still ongoing she didn't come out
outright and say but that is in fact
what she said uh her spin is that well
the pandemic still happened but it's
under control
and so when he said the pandemic is over
he actually meant that the pandemic is
not over but it's under control and why
did he say that because he was walking
around at a car show
I don't see the connection well of
course he thought the pandemic was over
we was walking around at a car show
you know when he saw a bunch of empty
cars and he didn't see covet in them so
he thought that's what was happening he
thought there was no coven
so it started her explanation started a
little bit rough and then but she
pivoted away from the car show and then
just started babbling about coveted
response and all this stuff like that
that was that's where we got to the
what what her job is
all right um
so I want to show you this
segment from and this is also for This
from NBC about the supposed right-wing
effort to ban books
um we hear a lot about this now in fact
sorry this is from CNN how do you tell
the difference anyway uh
we're constantly hearing about how on
the right we're out there just burning
books Banning books
now as a right way extremist myself and
as a stochastic terrorist I've never
been invited I'm a little bit offended
that all these book burnings are
happening on the right I've never even
been invited on but apparently this is
what we're doing I want you to watch how
this segment plays out though watch this
and are buried lead that's what we call
stories we do not think are getting
enough attention at least 50 groups are
fighting to ban books in U.S schools
that's according to Penn a non-profit
literary advocacy organization a new
report from Penn says these groups are
fighting to ban material related to race
and lgbtq rights and critical race
Theory and more joining us now to
discuss Jonathan Friedman he's the
director of free expression and
education programs at Pan America
Jonathan thanks for joining us your
report breaks down the subject matters
for the books that are currently there
there are pushes for them to be banned a
majority of them have lgbtq plus themes
or have a protagonist of color explain
more if you would and and obviously The
Devil's Advocate argument might be to a
parent out there hey I don't want my
first grade reading anything having to
do with sexuality much less lgbtq or
heterosexual anything
yeah thanks for having me I'm happy to
talk about this you know in District
after District we've been tracking book
bands efforts to remove and restrict and
diminish access to literature for young
people and the trends are very clear
that lgbtq books books that touch on
race and racism or books that have any
kind of sexual content you know whether
it's a book a young adult a work of
fiction that has a couple kissing or a
book teaching a young person about
puberty is on the chopping block and
it's the same books being targeted
everywhere now parents do have a right
to get involved have a voice bring their
concerns to teachers to Librarians to
school districts but increasingly we are
not seeing any kind of regular processes
being instituted in response to those
domain demands someone demands a book is
removed and they don't want it maybe for
their own child but immediately that
book is taken away for everybody else
you can't run schools that way yeah so
you notice that you notice what what you
notice what you don't notice there you
notice What's missing
and first of all he doesn't answer he
doesn't actually answer the question
from Jake Tapper what about parents who
say that there shouldn't be sexual
content of any kind especially in an
elementary school classroom or Library
doesn't answer that question other thing
they don't do is give any examples
of the books that are being banned
because it is true that we on the right
otherwise known as just like rational
morally decent people
which when they say the right that's
actually what they mean these days which
fine I'll accept it
but we we have called for Banning
certain books from the classroom
um
but those are books that are explicitly
sexual and graphic and that's why they
don't actually they don't give an
example they don't say well this
specific here's one specific book that
conservatives have wanted to take out of
the classroom here it is
that much less do they show you any of
the images from these books not going to
do that because if they did every single
even the average CNN viewer would see it
and say well that's in the classroom are
you kidding me
that's what you guys are complaining
about
one of the books uh and they're they're
only a sort of really a few books that
are in in contention here
and they're only in contention because
the left came along and said we want to
put these books into the classroom
and then we who are rational saying more
ladies and people said
no you're not putting that in the
classroom the left comes along and says
hey we got a great day we're gonna put
some pornography in the classroom and
then we say uh no I'm putting porn in
the classroom oh you book burners you're
just like Nazis
you're the one trying to inject this
stuff into the classroom the kids were
doing fine without it
well they don't want to give you an
example because one of one of the uh
most infamous examples of this book
genderqueer
which is a pornographic
it's kind of a graphic novel in graphic
and multiple senses of the word and
we've talked before about some of the
stuff that's in this book
there's pornographic stuff
depicting for example fellatio and those
sorts of things in the book pictures of
it
but they're not going to show you that
because like I said if they showed you
that the average CNN viewer even the
average CNN viewer if they showed okay
here's the book genderqueer here's
here's one of the books they want to uh
ban and here's the page that has really
been come under contention the most and
and there you see some you see someone
with a strap-on dildo and someone else
was performing fellatio on them that's
in the book
people watching CNN are going to say
what in the world you're telling me that
is in the classroom
yep
of course Tapper also says that uh the
other books that are being banned are
ones where there's a protagonist of
color because right because you've heard
conservatives call for that
I think of all the conservatives who
said no we don't want any books with
protagonists of color
get that book out of the classroom we've
seen all these school board meetings
where parents get up there and they and
they they present the books that they
found in their kids uh schools library
and they say we don't want this book how
many of those videos have we seen where
the parent stands up and has a book and
says this book doesn't belong in the
classroom it has a protagonist of color
in it
how many videos like that have you seen
well none at all because those are not
the books anyone has a problem with
we're very specific about this we just
don't want graphic pornographic
depictions in books given to kids in
elementary schools or at any other grade
level
that's all
that's our only point
um
let's see NBC has this report U.S
doctors should regularly screen all
adults under 65 for anxiety an
influential Health guidelines group
proposed on Tuesday it's the first time
the U.S preventive Services Task Force
has recommended anxiety screening and
primary care for adults without symptoms
The Proposal is open for public comments
until October 17th but the group usually
affirms its draft Guidance the
recommendations are based on a review
that began before the covid-19 pandemic
evaluating studies showing potential
benefits and risks from screening given
reports of a surge in mental health
problems linked with pandemic isolation
and stress the guidance is very timely
says Lori uh Bert a task force member
and co-author
actually your name is name is spelled p
b e r t p Bert the word pbert is a
psychologist researcher at the
University of Massachusetts Chan medical
school
so this is what they're recommending now
and this and they're recomming and the
recommendations always always end up um
becoming policy so this is going to be
the policy now we're going to do anxiety
screenings for adults without symptoms
and it's the kind of thing that I think
if you're not really clued in and paying
attention you might hear that and you
might say well it sounds like a good
idea sure extreme anxiety is a bad thing
and why not have a doctor screen for it
this is actually a terrible idea this is
an awful idea
because I tell you what this functions
as and I tell you what the purpose of it
is it is to funnel more and more people
into the pharmaceutical pipeline get
more and more people on drugs they want
to fight like we don't have enough
people on psychotropic drugs already we
don't have enough people on anti-anxiety
antidepressants already
even though with antidepressants the
whole the the the the the the medical
basis for antidepressants has been
destroyed now has been revealed to be a
fraud but still you know the millions of
people on these drugs not enough though
for the system they want even more
people and so now they're gonna they're
gonna start screening you for anxiety
symptoms
so they find a hint of anxiety they can
say well let's get him on a drug too
good news you get to be on a drug
screening for anxiety symptoms
everyone has anxiety it is The Human
Condition it is one of the most
uh
it's it's it is a Hallmark of The Human
Condition in fact there's anxiety it's
one of the things that separates us from
the animals
it's one of the defining traits of the
human psyche is anxiety
everyone has it every single person you
right now every single person watching
you all have anxiety all of you like
there's never been a person who has
walked through a day and not experienced
anxiety it has never happened ever in
the history of humanity
and so now for screening everyone for it
on a regular basis that means that what
do you know we're gonna we're gonna find
millions of more cases of anxiety and
that's millions of uh more customers for
the pharmaceutical industry
and not just funneling them into the
clutches of the pharmaceutical industry
but also into the clutches of therapists
and counselors
um which is a problem
as well because although in theory
therapy and counseling can be a good
thing I mean the whole idea between
behind therapies you go and you talk to
someone you talk about your problems in
theory that's a very good thing and
there are very good therapists and
counselors out there
but a lot of them are rabid ideologues
and gender ideology cultists with their
own agenda
and their agenda has nothing to do with
act with anything therapeutic they're
not looking to help you with your
problems
so for example here's a viral Tick Tock
posted by Libs of tick tock well
reposted she didn't post it initially
um
this is from a therapist
and this is a tick tock that he posted
and this is what therapy is today in so
many cases so we'll play it and we'll
read the captions up here but go ahead
and play it
so it says point of view your homophobic
transphobic parents drop you off to
therapy thinking I'm a hetero
and he starts dancing
me Queer as F here to validate your
feelings support you talk about
oppression and challenge your parents
then this is again something he posts
willingly to tick tock for everyone to
see
so he says here's what he's actually
here to do go put the back up on the
screen for a second
the end of that
what he's actually here to do
so the parents drop the kids off
thinking that well am I going to get my
kids therapy may they need some help
they have emotional problems makes sense
as a parent you'd like to think that you
that you could trust a therapist but he
says no that's not his agenda is not
that his agenda is because he's queer as
f is to validate your feelings support
you talk about oppression and challenge
your parents
that is not therapy that is not
counseling
uh validating your feelings
is is the not just not therapy that's
the opposite of what a therapist is
supposed to do
if the patient is going to sit down
there and um the client is going to sit
down there and you're going to validate
whatever they say why are they there
what are you there for what's the
function exactly
oh they're not supposed to be there to
validate whatever unreasonable
delusional
thing you might think
to validate your in a firm your lack of
perspective your confusions they're
supposed to be there for clarity
and perspective
and if a child isn't getting along with
his parents
the therapist is supposed to help heal
that relationship
help the child see more clearly help the
child understand his feelings and his
his thoughts
and help to heal the Divide between
parent and child
but now for so many of these people as
they will willingly announce for
everyone to see
they see their job as the opposite their
job is to sever the parent-child
relationship destroy it
and to take all of the mental confusion
that's causing the problem and um
encourage it
and there's going to be more victims as
we as we start screening people for
anxiety and depression and all these
other things uh that that means sending
them more into therapists and then what
happens
so someone gets screened maybe your kid
gets a little anxiety screening and the
doctor says yep got some anxiety let's
get him on drugs send him to a therapist
sits down with a therapist and the
therapist says well you know I've
figured out what your anxiety is all
about turns out that uh well you think
you're a boy but you're actually a girl
that's what the anxiety is
and your parents will tell you otherwise
don't listen to them they're a bunch of
scumbags and they're oppressive and
bigoted don't listen to them
this is the process
this is how you trans an entire
generation which is what they're doing
right now
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Matthew says
Bexar County is pronounced Bear County
for future reference please don't say
Bexar County again it is a macro
aggression not micro you're also
canceled for this offense no that's not
how it's pronounced
and there are many other comments too
because I talked about Bexar County and
the Democrat Sheriff down there that
wants to arrest Ron DeSantis all these
comments it's not it's pronounced Bear
County no you're wrong okay you live in
in Bexar County and and you are actually
wrong about how your own town is
pronounced I am telling you as an
outsider how to actually pronounce it
b-e-x-a-r is not pronounced bare there's
no version of the English language that
would arrive that that that can make
bear out of b-e-x-a-r
it's Bexar hate to tell you you've been
pronouncing it wrong this whole time
that's how you put like letters have
there are certain sounds that letters
make and this is how we this is how you
learn English in the first place this is
how we teach kids
and I know English can get a little
funky sometimes and you've got silent
letters and all these different things
but there have to be limits to it
okay you can't
we have to draw the line somewhere
that is Bexar County
Rachel says my eighth grader uh wrote he
Hall as his preferred pronouns in his
health class I told him that it was my
proudest parenting moment to date
and and rightfully so rightfully so
that is exactly how kids should respond
make a joke out of it make a mockery of
it fantastic J star says I thought Matt
was going to cancel the rapping Grandma
he was even reclining back in his chair
at the end of the video which he always
does but right before he tears into
somebody it just goes to show that
though we may know Matt Walsh we don't
really know him he is beyond our
understanding Beyond us mortal humans
Matt Walsh simply is
well why would you think that I would
want to can't well you're banned from
the show for that why would I cancel I
don't have a policy of canceling every
single person
who performs a kind of awkward and
embarrassing rap that's not a policy on
this show
if you've got the wholesome quotient I
might not be a very wholesome guy myself
I might not always appreciate wholesome
things
but you know what wholesomeness can go a
long way I think you can get you can get
away with a lot if you're wholesome and
the grandma she was wholesome and so
it's allowed
um Ashley says my favorite part of the
show is when Matt tells sweet stories
about his kids well they aren't just
sweet I mean I try to tell stories that
are funny I'm not up here like
let me tell you about another cute thing
my kid did
see there seems to be a bit of a false
narrative building here which is why I
want to address this because last night
one of our super fans on Twitter uh
after watching backstage she tweeted and
she said that she thought I was a I was
such a sweetheart during backstage
I said what what kind of irresponsible
misinformation is this this is dangerous
misinformation
and a threat to our democracy
I will tell you one sweet story about my
kid fine uh I last and there's no
nothing funny it happens at the end of
this but this is just I'll give you one
so uh last night I get home from
backstage
and my nine-year-old daughter comes out
of her room and says Daddy I'll be
waiting up for you I need to show you
something so she was waiting up to show
me so she waited like two hours she was
waiting up and then I go into her room
she hands me her little notepad where
she had written a song and uh and she
weighed up for like two hours to show me
the song that she wrote
and it was it was uh it's a very sweet
song and it was very nice
it was a little derivative of other
songs I've heard
you know there might be some plagiarism
a little bit but it was still it was
very it was very cute very nice
um
Peter Van Eden says hi Matt what
happened to that trans PhD student that
was calling for sending drugs to other
transgenders by mail that story became
very quiet uh I yeah Eli Ehrlich I have
not forgotten about that I can tell you
that
that's
just like Vanderbilt this is not
something that I'm going to forget about
because that's that's part of the story
so we have we have
um the ways that kids are legally right
now drugged and mutilated and we got to
do something about that
but then even when you stop it from
happening legally I mean that's going to
put that's going to save a lot of kids
and they're not just just on its own but
they're also the underground black
market operations uh Eli Ehrlich is one
example of that not the only one
so that's something we're working on too
I'll just tell you that we haven't
forgotten about it
um
I'll also say that not everything can be
achieved
by talking about it publicly
he birth Alvarez says careful Matt Ben
is trying to commit facial hair
appropriation you can't let him
appropriate flannel no I'm uh yeah I did
see Ben backstage last night had a
little bit of facial hair going on I uh
there's no appropriation here I always
welcome I'm very tolerant and welcoming
and inclusive
in the bearded facial hair community and
I welcome anybody in
I I I welcome anybody in a sort of like
a long lost brother you know so I think
that's a wonderful thing
um and finally Adam says Matt I
appreciated your discussion about porn
during backstage last night but I
thought you personally came off as
holier than thou and judgmental to those
who struggle with watching porn
with respect if you thought that from
watching the discussion Then I then I
could only think that you didn't you
weren't watching it very carefully
um just because we're talking about
something and saying that it's bad and
we shouldn't do it that doesn't it's
that's not holier than that holier than
now is if I were to stand up and say I
am better than all of you and I follow
my example
that's not how I approach any
conversation
we're just talking about the issue and
there are some realities with
pornography and none of the realities
are good it is a dirty shameful awful
thing
which is why men who suffer from porn
addiction want to get over I mean they
know this they don't need me to tell
them that
and they wouldn't disagree
I think and and you should that was the
members block of the
uh backstage last night which is another
reason to become a member so you can
watch great content like that but I
thought it was really interesting
conversation and and I I enjoy backstage
the most when we get into kind of
debates and arguments and the reason why
the debates are interesting is because
we agree fundamentally on the basic
um
principles
and when you agree on the basic
principles you can have much more
interesting arguments this is why
debates in our culture generally are so
in uninteresting and tedious and boring
and they don't they don't amount to
anything or go anywhere because there's
there's a fundamental disagreement about
the basic principles and so you can't
get anywhere in the conversation you
can't get past Square One
because you are you're you're you know
you're coming you're living in two
different universes
but when you can agree on the basic
principles then it allows you to get a
little bit deeper into the weeds and
talk about more interesting things and
so that was what was happening in the uh
in that porn conversation I'm not going
to rehash the entire thing I will just
reiterate some that point that I was
trying to make
in that that conversation
which is that
well there's two things
there's this idea that well all men look
at porn and there's nothing that can be
done about it everyone looks at it and
you can't you know you can't really stop
men from doing it Men Can't Stop
themselves uh that wasn't said exactly
in the conversation but you know there's
there's this idea in general that you
hear sometimes and
uh I reject that
you know I reject that it's uh
that it's this automatic uncontrollable
thing I reject it it's not true
it it is in fact possible to not look at
porn
now if you have an addiction and
especially if you've been
immersed in this addictions from
childhood
and you're very your fundamental Notions
of human sexuality have been warped and
perverted by this filth that you've been
swimming in from a young age then
getting past that that is very difficult
but it is possible
to not look at pornography like as a man
that doesn't have to be part of your
life
it's not a judgmental holier than thou
statement I think that's actually that's
a message of Hope like you don't have to
this is this is not uh this doesn't
automatically come with the territory it
is possible to have a life totally free
of this filth you can that is possible
very possible
but the other part of it is that I think
we have to
validate to use the left to use the
leftist term they're validate
the feelings of women and of wives who
feel totally devastated and destroyed by
their husbands looking at pornography I
mean the way they see it
is when they're you know their husbands
upstairs looking at other people have
sex while she's down taking care of the
kids I mean she sees this as a total
betrayal
and I agree with her she should see it
that way
she's not crazy for seeing it that way
that's how men should see it
gives you all the more motivation to try
to free yourself from this
because when you look at porn especially
if you're a married man that is not a
victimless
crime
um it's it's not neutral you you're
actually hurting people I mean you're
hurting yourself and you're hurting your
family and your wife and your kids
you're hurting everybody
it's closest to people you love the most
so that's the point I want to wanted to
make
I'm not sure what you see the whole year
than now in that
there are two ways to absolutely stop
the left Edge tracks their first is to
point out their lunacy the second is to
take as much money away from them as
possible and if you're a regular a
regular listener to this show you're
doing the former if you made the
decision to stop supporting Harry's or
Gillette and go to Jeremy's razors then
you're doing both now uh but if you
haven't heard yet we've got a brand new
incentive for you it's the Jeremy's
razors contest for the car why do we
call it that because it's a contest for
a car here's how it works for every
person you refer whether they buy a
Jeremy's Razor's kit or a deadly wire
annual membership you both get points in
the race to win the god Kings McLaren if
someone from the sweet baby gang wins
this thing it'll warm my heart so get
out there and start hustling to sign up
and start competing go to
jeremy'srazors.com play the race for the
car ends on November 1st so get into the
competition today see terms and
conditions for complete details at
Jeremy's racers.com referral terms the
program is open only to the legal to
Legal us residents residing the U.S D.C
excluding residents of Colorado
Connecticut Maryland Puerto Rico and U.S
territories and possessions 18 and older
remember friends don't let friends shave
with woke razors now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so you have at this point certainly
heard the story about the teacher in
Canada who enjoys wearing giant
prosthetic breasts to class acting out
his perverse sexual fantasies in front
of his students in fact he forces them
to participate in effect in his fetish
against their will just by being there
the story has resonated because I think
it's so disturbing and weird and
shocking that's one reason why it's
caught people's attention
um nobody could have predicted it
exactly but I think this pervert in
Canada with his giant fake breasts may
serve as a as a turning point for the
culture because people can finally see
where gender ideology leads even those
who to this point generally went along
with it using preferred pronouns and so
on all in the name of being polite they
wanted to be polite now they're
beginning to notice the slope that
they're rapidly slipping down because if
you start affirming everybody no matter
how degraded their self-perception might
be you quickly end up with things like
this you end up with fetishes wearing
sex aids to school
and that's far from the worst of it
but not everybody is ready to condemn
the man with the fake breasts Peter
bakassian who is uh who builds himself
as a philosopher tweeted a picture of
the infamous fetishes along with the
caption quote
most people have strong moral impulses
about whether this individual should be
allowed to teach their children in a
public school but very few can construct
a good argument why or why not it's more
difficult than you think try it
well actually Peter it's not difficult
at all I mean you might as well claim
that it's difficult to come up with an
argument against setting puppies on fire
or touching torching nursing homes it is
very easy to explain why these things
are bad in the case of the teacher I can
do it in one sentence
you shouldn't act out your sexual
fetishes in front of children
there done
I could add you know I could add to that
that you shouldn't act out your sexual
fetishes at work at all even if you
don't work with children
you shouldn't act them out in public
so there are there are three good
arguments against this Behavior that's
only a very partial list
but what is Peter's actual point I mean
why is he pretending that the freak with
the the big fake boobs presents some
sort of complex moral dilemma why is he
acting like this is something that Greek
philosophers might have might have
written about and argued about
perhaps Aristotle wrote A Treatise on
fetish gear in the classroom
I'll have to check I'm not sure
well I think that what we really see
here is first the insistence
that we cannot condemn anything unless
we're able to come up with a universal
generalized overarching principle for
everything that that um that and that
and that if there are any potential
exceptions at all to the principle then
the condemnation is automatically
invalid
so this is this is the idea
you can't get that many you have to
unless you have an overarching General
principle that applies to it and if
there are any exceptions to that
principle then the principle no longer
holds
this is the attitude on the left which
is why you can never get them to talk
about any specific thing immediately
they'll go to the exceptions which are
supposed to negate whatever you said
about the specific thing that was not an
exception so how does this relate to the
dude with the big fake boobs well
I imagine that if you condemn the
prosthetic breasts
somebody like Peter would respond well
why is it wrong to wear Prosthetics
what about a teacher with a prosthetic
leg huh what about that
gotcha
and even if you hinge your argument as I
did on the idea that adults shouldn't be
acting out their fetishes in front of
children
somebody like Peter might retort with
something like are all fetishes bad but
what if someone has a fetish for wearing
pants
does that mean they they shouldn't wear
pants in the classroom
ha got you again
this is how they play the game if you
know if you think I'm exaggerating
consider that the left has actually
argued and has been arguing uh today
after this after the Vanderbilt expose
they argue that it's invalid to
criticize double mastectomies for gender
confused girls
because sometimes girls need double
mastectomies as breast cancer treatment
so they take two completely different
situations which are extremely easy to
distinguish between and claim that
because there is one through line
connecting them you automatically cannot
condemn the one without condemning the
other
like they act as though the only way to
condemn double mastectomies for teenage
girls is to argue that double
mastectomies in and of themselves are
wrong all the time
it's an utterly absurd tactic but this
is what most debates on the internet
boil down to
I think there's something else going on
here too
Peter acknowledges that most people have
a strong moral impulse against this kind
of activity
yet he declares that this moral impulse
isn't sufficient
like we have to come up with a rational
argument against it
in this case you know we can we can come
up with rational arguments easily in
this case it's not it's not actually
hard to do
but even if we couldn't putting that
aside
why isn't our moral impulse good enough
why isn't it good enough he says people
have moral impulses this is wrong
okay well
say no more I mean we you acknowledge
this is our moral impulse tells us that
it's wrong to behave this way
why do you need more than that
this is something we all inherently
recognize as wrong almost everyone in
the world knows it's wrong to wear
fetish gear in front of kids
the people who actually do it also know
that it's wrong which is part of the
sixth thrill they derive from it their
masochist titillated by humiliation and
also excited by breaking taboos
as for the people who
don't personally engage in this Behavior
yet would defend it on principle most of
them like the school administrators who
defended him they know that it's
perverse and gross but they feel
compelled to accept it in the name of
gender identity and tolerance
any small fraction of people remaining
who are not themselves fetishes but
genuinely don't believe that this
activity is wrong well it's easy to
explain them through a combination of
mental illness and deep moral confusion
ingrained in them practically from birth
by the nihilistic degraded culture they
live in
so we have a world
where almost everyone intuitively
inherently sees that this sort of
activity is wrong
along maybe along with a small minority
who don't see it because they're
mentally Disturbed and deluded
well Peter says that's that's that's not
good enough
we have to be able to explain these
things things that everyone knows and if
we can't explain them then the thing can
be ignored or discarded
this is the trick the left has been
pulling for decades our inherent moral
intuition as human beings must be
explained to their satisfaction
or else they're entitled to just ignore
it completely
but that's not true
it's not how it works
and it also unfairly flips the burden of
proof around see it's not up to you or
to me to explain why grown men should
not play out their sexual fantasies in
front of kids
I can explain it but that's not my job
if Pete or anybody else thinks that this
activity is acceptable
it's up to them to present their
arguments defending it
so you see the tactic here if we can't
rationally defend our moral intuition
then they can do whatever they want
but they don't have to rationally defend
anything
it's all us they don't have to defend or
explain anything we have to defend and
explain everything
we have to tell them why they shouldn't
do it they don't have to tell us why
they should
except again that's not how it works
like if you're coming along and
insisting that the moral impulse shared
by nearly everyone in the world is wrong
you have to make your case
you have to present your evidence and
convince us that actually it's good for
men to wear enormous fake boobs in the
classroom
the burden of proof is on you
it's on you when the Man shows up with
the giant fake boobs he no no he can't
say well give me one good reason why I
shouldn't wear these
no no
you you freaking weirdo you give me one
good reason why you should
you're the one showing up here like that
explain to me explain yourself explain
to me why you are acting that way
I don't have to explain myself
I'm not the one doing something bizarre
and ridiculous and gross that's you you
explain yourself
but that's a burden you can't meet
which is why they always try to flip the
conversation around and put the onus up
on us as if our conviction that children
should not be participants in the sexual
fetishes of adults is some sort of
radical idea in need of explanation it
isn't we need to explain nothing
we need only say to Peter boghosian and
his friend with the breasts
you're canceled
and I'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
Godspeed
as we move into our members block okay
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]